well you put all the other concerns
aside the krona virus epidemic is a
profound shared experience for the
country everybody is being affected in a
big way some people are at the brink of
sanity for being cooped up in small
apartments all day others are having
shared family meals for the first time
in a long time Adam Carolla is a
comedian a podcast host one of most
popular in the world and a general voice
of wisdom he's the author of the new
book
I'm your emotional support animal we
texted him late last night asked him to
come on to put some perspective on the
shutdown we're all living through we're
happy to have him here now hang Adam so
like a lot I don't know if you're in
seclusion where you are but a lot of
people are and it's a bewildering
experience how should we think about
this well first thing I'm doing my
podcast every day so you can hear it a
podcast one and we're going to keep the
gears turning you know it's a prison
sentence it's a short prison sentence
and as they say as a convict say you can
do the time or the time can do you and I
figure you should do the time meaning go
out build a tree house with your son and
daughter cook lasagna with your wife
don't let the time do you don't end up
with a face tattoo and a toilet filled
with prison wine you go out and use this
little snapshot in life to live your
life people are finding that hard and
I'm not criticizing or judging but it's
just it's so different
I mean people seem like they're
struggling with the you know being being
confined and being solitary yeah well I
you know I have a sort of philosophy
which is when has changed and I'll just
say this to all your viewers in your
life when has change really been bad big
picture you know the girlfriend that
dumped you the boyfriend that dumped you
the boss that fired you but when you
look back after a couple of years
immediately it's bad like right now it's
bad in a month it might still be bad but
in two years I think you look at these
little changes in
life is a good day that's the time you
learn to play Stratego with your 9 year
old son whatever it is yeah I think
philosophically change is always good
even negative change is good with time
huh so what are the changes you're
looking forward to well I think just
getting off of the treadmill of life I
think we're all sort of funneled toward
this treadmill and I know you feel it I
feel it we all feel it you have to make
hay while the Sun shines this is a time
just to reflect literally just some
quiet time it's like forced meditation
for those of us without a yogi you know
I talked to Kevin Bacon on my podcast
the other day he said he and his wife
did a crossword oh no they did a puzzle
like a 5,000 piece puzzle and he said
for the first time ever my wife meaning
they've been married for 33 years my
wife said let's do a puzzle together
would that ever happen that's amazing so
what do you think we're gonna learn now
that we're forced to take a pause get
off the treadmill experience little
silence I think we're gonna learn
something about ourselves hopefully
we're going to learn that it's not all
about the bottom line hopefully we're
gonna learn that family is more
important than your savings account
they're both important but I think we
have a chance to like stop in
reprioritize and shift just a little bit
huh you think people will do that I mean
that would require getting off Netflix
though - right well again do you want to
do the time or you want the time to do
you we really all have to look at this
as a small window we're almost in prison
you want to come out with a great novel
or you want to come out with a venereal
disease so those here shorts is the
great novel or the venereal disease I
actually think what you said is about
the most hopeful thing I have heard and
I mean that since this all began and I
that you would put it in perspective for
us Adam Carolla thank you very much for
that